money is money i would say it's much  harder to get money than to stay in  shape yep absolutely 100 percent so so  if a guy if a guy wants to make 120  pounds right a year i think that's much  harder than losing 50 pounds  okay and so what what i don't like is  lying to women and we cuddle them from  bad decisions and we take all the  accountability off of them and keep  allowing them to make bad decisions  instead of instead of telling them the  truth and saying hey if you want this  guy this is the way you can get it  but it's not a lie to tell a bigger  woman that she's beautiful  but here's here's the thing it is  because most of society doesn't see her  as beautiful  and so you could say oh f beauty  standards but we know they exist you you  know who's your prettiest friend  you you guys know you guys know deep  down when you walk into a room you you  know